thanks for the invitation to speak here
it's a pleasure to come down to stamford
in which is now the berkeley summer and
still the stanford quarter um i'm going
to talk today it's kind of a new talk
and reflects some more recent work in my
group but also some of the older work
and kind of blends that together
and it's really trying to think about
this perspective about um about dealing
with other agents as you're designing
the control systems and the you know the
interaction of a system with other
agents whether they be people or whether
they be other kind of autonomous or
semi-autonomous agents how should you
think about that interaction and and um
it's something that we've kind of had
this uh
you know evolving of opinion on but but
really the um
the the kind of heart of what we've been
doing in my group
since the beginning really was to focus
on safety
i work a lot on safety critical systems
and you'll see some of those
applications here but we are really
interested in
you know physical systems we do a lot
with air traffic control i'll show you a
couple of those projects and um you know
robotic systems where safety you know
you have systems that are interacting
close to people where you have
transportation systems where people are
involved and safety critical is really
important so so being able to have
proofs of safety and guarantees of
safety is something that we've had a big
focus on in my research group
um but you know traditional safety as
you saw from that previous slide has
quite a bit of like isolation you know
you have um an aircraft and an air
traffic control system that is guided by
human air traffic controllers on the
ground you know guiding through voice
channels um talking to the pilot guiding
the aircraft from its origin to his
destination through several sectors
train systems you know they're isolated
on tracks and when you see these robotic
systems for example in manufacturing
they're kind of in cages or they're
isolated from the people typically that
are using them and that's where you know
that is starting to be um relaxed in all
of those areas so this is a this is an
air traffic control project that we've
had kind of a long-standing
collaboration with nasa ames which is
close to stanford and it's a project
where we were we spent a lot of time
observing the functions of human air
traffic controllers as they were
watching you know sitting on the ground
seeing through radar screens the
aircraft that were coming into their
sectors and then observing what they did
and trying to build decision support
systems for these air traffic
controllers so this is actually a um an
outcome of a
one of the particular traces that we did
this is sector 33 part of the oakland uh
center
and um you know as you air aircraft come
close together there are multiple ways
that air traffic controllers tend to
tend to space them apart and they can do
this typically they try to do that by
time you know speeding up or slowing
down an aircraft just by a little bit to
maintain a certain requisite distance
but in some cases like this one they
have to do like deviations from paths
and then they try to use shortcuts so if
they're going to veer off into a new jet
way anyway why don't you do a shortcut
so that you can get you know faster and
and then avoid collision at the same
time so building an automated system
that kind of mimics what the human in
the loop controllers have been doing
historically is something that it's an
interesting direction right it's not
necessarily what we think of as control
engineers or people that work on
autonomous systems uh because we might
find a better way to do it but in a
system that has been guided for decades
by human air traffic controllers and
there's a lot of trust built up an air
traffic controller won't necessarily
just take any solution that a neural net
might give
you know from a decision support system
so just to really be built on kind of
thinking about where they are today and
gradually taking steps and that's one of
the projects that we continue to work on
with nasa
and here there's a lot of multi-agent
interactions right it's a you know air
traffic control system you have multiple
aircraft each each sector of aircraft
like this this region inside the magenta
bounds typically has between 12 and 15
aircraft you know that's kind of the
maximum but you know in peak times 12 to
15 aircraft at any given time so those
multi-agent interactions are important
um and you know even with the air
traffic control system but also in the
other applications i talked about
there's a growing number of new
applications and and we've been working
with some of these folks so some this is
an older picture of amazon prime air
zipline is a really cool uav company
that's delivering medicines they started
off in some of the countries in africa
and now they're um they're in the u.s
they're teaming up with walmart to
deliver uh medicines automatically
they're called zipline because they
don't have landing gear they come in and
the the aircraft basically have a hook
and they're grabbed by hooking onto a
zip line and that's the capture system
so there's a there's kind of a
deployment and then a recovery of the
aircraft and it's it's a really cool
engineering problem but also that
multi-agent interaction of having a lot
of these delivering medicines and they
started medicines and blood to areas
that are you know kind of remote and
don't have easy access to hospitals or
medical centers
we're working also with um nasa on air
traffic air taxi so the new air taxi
system which is kind of an exciting
area there's kind of the vehicle concept
this is one of the concepts that lilium
which is a german company is building
it's a tilt rotor system where the
aircraft has a vertical mode so it can
you know
take off and land in urban areas and
then the rotors tilt so that you can
turn it into a conventional aircraft
there's a whole bunch of neat control
problems there but there's also a kind
of neat um a neat problem in thinking
about how you integrate these new kinds
of aircraft like uavs like air taxis
into the traditional air traffic system
so that's the you know the kinds of
systems we've been working on with nasa
include collision avoidance systems
forced landing systems for example for a
uav if it has to land how do you do that
safely so they're they're you know it's
often that you don't care about crashing
the aircraft you don't want to hurt
anybody who's on the ground for example
and then this air taxi control system
um we're also there there's a bunch of
really interesting kind of other vehicle
style applications that you know
obviously there's the autonomous vehicle
scenario and that's something that we're
also working on but these are kind of
outside this so an inter a drug
interdiction system is something that
that the navy and the coast guard is
very interested on and and they're
interested in trying to interdict small
ships that are coming from south america
delivering drugs to central america that
are then carried over land into the u.s
and this is a big big focus right now
and so the office of naval research is
asking for new research solutions to be
able to take the few resources
that the coast guard and the navy can
provide and kind of be able to
distribute those or figure out you know
of the many many small ships they're
trying to interdict what are the what
are predictive ways what are ways to
infer you know what those ships are
doing all sorts of interesting control
and learning problems there so i have a
couple of um you know vehicle style
application problems examples in my talk
but um but these are some kind of
motivations of how we you know some new
maybe some new problems on the horizon
that where multi-agent
interactions are really featured
so i'm structured this talk really
around three research projects they're
kind of like vignettes
and they they kind of
move um from maybe more strict
assumptions about the other agents in
the system to relaxing those so i'm
going to start off by talking about it's
an older project in my group but older
and current we've been working on this
for a long time and i'd like to
introduce it as it sets a stage for how
you know how we've traditionally thought
about multi-agent interactions in safety
critical systems and that's through
reachability then we're going to move on
to the second
kind of vignette which is um
relaxing this idea that's used in
reachability of you know worst case of
worst actions of the other agent worst
case actions of the other agents in the
system and um and think more about um
you know the
less worst case actions the role of
feedback as well as computationally
efficient methods when you have that
scale to multiple to many agents
um there's some um there's some choice
of parameters involved in these problems
and then so in the last vignette i'm
going to talk about how you might use
learning to aid in choosing these
parameters to infer models and behaviors
of um of the other agents in the system
and i
i as i said this is a new talk i was
kind of thinking about the projects that
are going on here that i've seen and
observed so meng shi and airdems
projects and and some of the um you know
research that mac and marco have
presented up at berkeley recently and
michael to kind of think about you know
what's going on here and how might the
kinds of things we're doing in my group
interface or connect with some of those
projects
okay so let's start just by this um what
is going to be kind of a review but more
like an introduction review of what
reachability is and and the assumptions
that we use when we compute reachable
sets so uh we call it hamilton jacobi
reachability because at the heart of the
computation is an optimal control or
differential game problem in this case
with uh like multiple players we use a
differential game formulation
and there's you know we're building on
um i would say uh you know a long
history of differential game theory
where we derive a new problem basically
a new bellman equation that can be used
to compute reachable sets and a lot of
the challenge has been to first of all
represent that and then compute those
reachable sets based on that um that
formulation and that's called a hamilton
jacobi it's a it's a new type of
hamilton jacobi equation okay so let me
kind of give a background as what that
means
um we're assuming that the the
underlying systems the agents have
dynamics associated to them and and you
can represent the joint dynamics of
those systems as some kind of dynamic
system either a differential equation as
is represented here with state z
and input u and disturbance d or some um
difference equation for example but
there's some kind of dynamics that can
model the system itself
and they may be uncertain you may be
able to kind of lump the uncertainty
about the behavior for example in in the
disturbance which is often what we do
so a reachable set is the set of states
um and there's different flavors but
let's consider a problem where your
control is trying to get the system
trying to get maybe one of the agents to
a desired target
in the face of you know other agents
which may be disrupting the plans
so in that sense let's think about the
control as an action which is trying to
get the system to a target set in the
face of a disturbance which we may not
know what it's going to do but let's
assume for the sake of safety critical
control that it may be trying to do its
worse to
disrupt those plans so all states for
which for all possible disturbances
there's a control which can drive the
system into a target set over a time
horizon and so given that formulation we
use a or given that statement we use a
game formulation for this
a dynamic game in which the disturbance
attempts to force the system into unsafe
region we don't know what it's going to
do so let's assume that it could do its
worst to disrupt the control's plans
while the control is trying to keep the
system safe trying to get it to its
target
um
and these are animations that uh sylvia
herbert who's a former student in my
group had created so i'm i'm i'm
gratefully using her um animations for
this so if this for example is the
target set in green
um then for a you know a particular
dynamic um f this is a possible
reachable set this is actually a
reachable set of a um it's like a
dubin's car style model of those
dynamics
okay so how did we come about that um
the
the
methodology that we use is to take that
set and represent it as the zero level
set of a function in one higher
dimension so that's the cost function it
represents the the goal the objective
the target set here
um and that's uh we'll use some
functional representation so you've you
know many different functions who have
that set as the zero level set so you
choose one here it's just a
distance to uh distance to target set
function that we're using so that the
zero level set of that function is the
target set itself and we'll use a
representation l to represent that set
okay so what then do we want to compute
we'd like to compute all states which
could get to that target set um despite
the worst case disturbance so we define
a value based on that goal of reaching
that set and that value is a function of
the state space in this case we're using
z
uh so in this uh example it's a
two-dimensional state space and
it's a function of time over a time
horizon so basically every state z at
time t
has a value associated to it which is
like the future rewards or penalties
that are incurred by the system being at
that state at that particular time and
in this problem that's solely related to
whether or not it gets inside or stays
outside the set over that time horizon
so to do that we
basically define this value function as
the minimum cost of trajectories of the
system starting from state z at time t
okay so this is you know why do we use
minimum because we're looking at this
function we've we've decided that we're
going to represent um kind of goodness
as being inside that set at some point
over the time horizon and so if you want
to try to be inside that site you want
to try to minimize that function l so
the minimum over the time horizon from 0
to capital t of that function l
evaluated on the trajectory itself
and we don't have to actually so here's
where some control can come in we don't
actually have to evaluate it on all
possible trajectories we only really
have to evaluate it on the best
trajectory the trajectory where we use
our best control input to get the system
into the target set
um so that's here's the trajectory
itself the trajectory is a function you
know it's an it's a solution of that
differential or difference equation or
whatever dynamics you use but it's a
solution of that system using the
you know the a particular control and
disturbance input and if you're
to be efficient we don't have to
evaluate over all control and
disturbance inputs we just have to use
the optimal trajectory so the best for
the control despite the worst case
disturbance and that's the one where the
control is trying to get the system into
the set so it's trying to
minimize that function l over the
trajectories whereas we don't know what
the disturbance will do in this
formulation so we'll assume that the
disturbance could do its worse it could
try to maximize it push push you outside
that set because it's maximizing the
function l evaluated over that
trajectory
okay so given that definition we can
define
the
bellman backup equation or the update
equation or the hamilton jacobi equation
they're all the same thing here and this
is um well hamilton jacobi actually
isaacs was the one back in the 30s well
the 40s and 50s who did a lot of work on
games so these are often called hamilton
jacobi isaacs equations which in this
continuous time continuous state setting
is a partial differential equation which
describes the on the left hand side the
change in that value function as a
function of time and on the right hand
side it's a function of the state and
the gradient the change in that value
function as a function of state which in
our case is quite simple we don't have a
running cost here we just care about
whether or not the system gets into the
state over the time gets into the target
set over the time horizon so we're just
looking at this um hamiltonian which is
the inner product between the dynamics
and the gradient of the value function
okay and um in terms of computing it
we've been moving away from
using the actual pde representation and
we're using now in our codes this
variational inequality it allows us in
general to um have a more general
representation of targets for example we
can use time-varying targets with this
representation and um it has some also
some computational um
uh benefits so this is basically a it's
still a partial differential equation
but this kind of way that we represent
it here as the minimum of the pde and
the initial data is called a variational
inequality
okay so so now we solve that so this is
um you know we have to basically grid up
the state space and compute that value
function
using that pde
at every point in the state space over
time
and so what we're doing here is we're
basically evaluating the
we're evaluating this function v of x t
for all or v of z t for all state z and
for all points in time over that time
horizon
and um and then updating it over time so
over that time horizon that value
function it starts at the initial green
cone and then expands out into this
particular set
so it basically says that every state z
at time t has a value and whether or not
you're you know inside the zero level
set of that value or outside the zero
level set of that value indicates
whether or not that state indicates
whether or not there exists a control
such that for all possible disturbances
starting at that state you can get to
the target set over that time horizon so
at each time we're capturing the zero
level set and that captures the
reachable set
okay so we just take that zero level set
so here we are back to this reachable
set that we showed at the beginning but
that's how we compute it we we represent
sets implicitly through a value function
in one higher dimension and then we're
always recording i mean other values
other level sets are interesting too but
generally the zero level set is what we
record because that represents that sort
of binary decision of yes you're
captured or no you're not captured over
the time horizon
okay so that's the reachable set
and you can do other things too you can
include for example um
state constraints in this problem so we
um we've also have you know interesting
problems where you'd like to reach a
target but avoid some other sets along
the way you'd like to maintain some
constraints so those states the
constraints can also be represented as a
value function this is the the red set
here so instead of using l for the
target set let's use g for the
constraint set
and then we can update the
representation of the value function to
include that state constraint it's like
a it's like a mask on the computation of
the reachable set you're just making
sure that you can't it's not only that
you want to rule out states inside the
constraints but you want to rule out
states in the reachable set that could
get to the constraint before they get to
the actual target set so it's like
you've combined together two
reachability problems one which is
getting to the target set and one which
is avoiding the constraint set
and and then we update the
the actual hamilton jacobi pde according
to those constraints um and then do the
you know the same kind of computation
which is a gridding up of the state
space and solving that pde at each point
in uh space and at each point in time so
that's that's the computational
challenge which we'll talk about
okay so again thanks to sylvia herbert
for these nice animations captures the
zero level set so here you see what we
call this reach avoid set sets of states
which get to the target while avoiding
that constraint
okay and please feel free to interrupt
and ask questions if you have questions
along the way you can ask questions at
the end
okay so um like a collision avoidance
problem we talked about some of these uh
air traffic control or air taxi problems
um so these are these um computed
reachable sets for a pairwise uh
collision avoidance problem
here the dimension because we're only
dealing with two aircraft and we're
looking at collision avoidance we can
look at the relative dynamics so the
dynamics the underlying dynamics f
become the relative dynamics between
those two vehicles and then we're going
to place the we'll call them pursuit
pursuer and evader using the kind of
traditional isaac's game theoretic terms
and then in those in that relative
coordinates space we'll place the evader
at the origin and and these aircraft
have uh
some kind of turning angle so we'll
place them at the origin of the relative
frame with a zero uh heading angle and
then i've just shown a snapshot of the
pursuer in each case that's just to
indicate that the pursuer i'm looking at
this is a three-dimensional set because
i've have a an x-dot y-dot and z and
theta-dot where that's the those are the
three states um but i'm going to take a
slice of that three-dimensional set at
the case of the pursuer being at that
kind of 90 degree away from the
zero angle and just look at what those
sets look like and i think the reason i
wanted to show this computation to you
is to illustrate you know how these
computations can change when you have
different information assumptions
between the agents so kind of leading to
our thought about okay what are we
assuming about the multiple agents in
this uh in this game um
in the first case on the left is um
maybe the you know in terms of the uh
evader pursuer problem it's the one
which is um assuming the most about the
system which or in which the evader
assumes the most about the pursuer
namely that um they you know there's a
communication loss with the pursuer but
the so the evader is assuming that the
pursuer is operating according to some
disturbance bound doesn't know exactly
what it's going to do but it knows it
has kind of a bound in what it can do
and it will stay to that
and so this reachable set and you can
see these indices over time represents
the relative states where the pursuer
can be and collision avoidance cannot be
guaranteed so if the pursuer managed to
play its worst if it were inside that
reachable set at any of those time
stamps
um
the uh best control action of the evader
will not keep the two aircraft apart
from each other and a part is that uh
defined by that basically that disk
around the evader okay so this is just
that hamilton jacobi reachable solution
when we're assuming that the disturbance
is the action of the pursuer and we've
given a bound on that
a more a less conservative approach is
to assume that both aircraft we've lost
communication with both aircraft we
don't know what we don't know what the
pursuer is going to do within its bounds
but we also don't know what the evader
is going to do within its bounds so now
instead of thinking about that as a
control disturbance problem it's like we
have two disturbances what's the you
know if the evader did its worst case
and the pursuer did its worst case
within bounds what does that reachable
set look like what does that collision
set look like and you can see its growth
it's actually kind of interesting it um
it grows out and then because these
dynamics are like a dubin's car it kind
of circles around again so you get a new
part of the reachable set growing in
that middle panel kind of above the the
previous reachable set and you can see
there's like again time stamps
associated to each of those
um and then the real worst case scenario
so the the one that maybe puts the least
assumptions on what the vehicles could
do is one where they actually try to
collaborate to cause collision so it's
not like the middle case where you know
they must by by kind of you know
choosing the wrong thing accidentally
they could uh cause collision in the
right panel they're collaborating and so
they're really acting with each other to
try to cause collision and um and you
see that you know now the set's growing
even more so it's the same computation
but just different assumptions instead
of using like a min max we'd be using a
min min etc in these in these different
kind of information patterns what you're
assuming you know and then what the
implication would be in the game
formulation
okay i put this in this is from a long
time ago but this is actually robly
field up here i used to be a professor
here at stanford and we built maybe the
first this is before you could buy a
quad rotor like anywhere we built those
um these are built out of um
carbon tube
carbon tubes and tube straps and we had
two computers and we you know we
actually designed one of the computers
and we ran another computer running the
optimization algorithms on it so and
there's four students there they're each
joysticking one quadrotor around
and um the snapshot on the right is just
a data snapshot so around each aircraft
are three different reachable sets
one reachable set for each of the three
other aircraft
and this is one of these interesting
problems where because of the dynamics
of the vehicles and the fact that they
can essentially stop and hover you can
prove that the actual unsafe set like
the collision zone is the union of the
collision zones with respect to you know
each uh a vehicle with respect to each
of the three other vehicles
and so at every point in time we're
computing these and when one vehicle
gets on the boundary of its reachable
set with respect to another vehicle the
other vehicle takes its best case uh
control action to keep that vehicle
outside of the regional side it does
that that
control input which basically in this
case it's an avoidance problem so it's
maximizing the control input to keep the
other aircraft away from from causing
collision and getting into its reach of
the set
so it's like pilots the students are
joysticking the aircraft around as soon
as one gets on the boundary of another
the automation takes over and guides the
aircraft away from each other until a
point in time where it's you know a
little bit off the boundary and then
control is given back
to the for the pilot
so this was a a kind of both
demonstration and an experiment to show
this off that you could do this and you
could compute these
okay just a little bit about the
toolboxes so the first level set method
so we this um method for computing the
reachable set this gridding up of the
state space and solving that hamilton
jacobi equation and capturing the zero
level set um that's called a level set
method they were
pioneered like the numerical methods
were pioneered by stan osher who's a
professor in math at ucla and jamie
sethian who's a professor in math at
berkeley
and um and so we took like sort of
inspiration from that and built these
level set methods for these kinds of
control problems and um and so this is
the reference to this original level set
toolbox which ian mitchell who was a
graduate from stanford he was my first
phd student
he's now a professor
and department chair of computer science
at ubc in vancouver
um and then over the past several years
we've had updates to this so we built in
our group
a toolbox we call it helper oc it's like
a wrapper around ian's level set toolbox
this was um written by a couple of
different students but led by mo chen
and sylvia herbert moe is now at simon
fraser university in vancouver and
sylvia is now a professor at ucsd
and they um they basically made it more
easy to use providing this wrapper you
know easy ways to input your own
dynamics
easy ways to capture the value function
and you know that like to guide you in
formulating the problem
and that's on our labs reachability site
and then most recently we've been using
and this is a really cool toolbox it's
the hj reachability toolbox which was
built by ed schmerling who is a graduate
of stanford from marco pavone's group
and
this is a toolbox built in python and
it's built on top of the jacks
computational framework
and we have been doing some work with
this toolbox and have built a number of
additional functions to use with this so
one of those and this is just a little
bit of an aside this is a project that
my student marius wigart and i have been
working on with um manon doshi and
pierre larmuso who are researchers at
mit
it's a carbon sequestration project
where we're building light vehicles well
we're working with a company that's
building light vehicles that are seaweed
farms and we're trying to use minimum
energy paths to get these vehicles their
you know surface vehicles in the ocean
to areas of high nutrients where they
can where the seaweed grows quickly and
then it can be at a certain stage
deposited in the ocean floor so it
sequesters carbon from the um from the
air from the environment and then
deposits it where it kind of you know
stays for for centuries and millennia
and maybe turns into oil at some point
um but the idea here was to really use
minimum energy control by putting a very
kind of low control input here that kind
of nudges the vehicles toward currents
and then we use those currents to get us
to places where we want the vehicle to
go so this is the gulf of mexico
and if you um you know if you wanted to
get you can see these are there's a lot
of databases with you know forecasts as
well as we can use those for hindcast
and if you wanted to get from one point
to a destination using those currents
uh that
that magenta arrow up there just shows
if you took it actually takes 33 days
using the currents and using the
hamilton jacobi methodology but if you
um if you didn't you know if there were
zero currents that arrow at the top just
shows how far you would have gone over
33 days with just this uh small control
input um and the you know it's kind of
neat to watch the trajectory using these
eddies and these currents to as we say
hitchhike them to be able to get from
the origin to the destination but the
point i want to make here is that you
know using helper oc to compute that
trajectory we were using backwards
reachability for that trajectory because
you not only get the reachable set but
you get the optimal control input that
took three hours whereas in the hj
reachability which is taking advantage
of parallel processing across gpus it
took
a much shorter time only eight minutes
okay so those are kind of
state-of-the-art in um i would say this
is state of the art in hamilton jacobi
reachability and it's great to be able
to use that
um i'd like to say one more thing about
computing these reachable sets and um
this is recent work that we've done
because it is you know gridding up the
state space and despite even if we have
that hj reachability tool you know if we
want to do these computations in real
time how do we do that um and one of the
ideas that we had been exploring with
samuel bonsal who's a recent graduate of
our group he's now on the faculty at usc
is to um
instead of gridding up the state space
and um and then just you know sort of
blindly computing the hamilton jacobi
updates at each grid point over time
we train a neural net to compute that
value function for us
and i think the idea is pretty cool
because you um you can actually take
advantage of you know the the neural net
to be able to learn you know what are
the what are the best points to compute
at there's probably you know a whole lot
of the grid points that are fairly you
know fairly important and then others
which aren't important at all and we've
done a lot of work on you know adaptive
gridding and trying to choose those
ourselves but the logic to do that was
always more cumbersome than actually
just doing the computation so i feel
like this is a this is actually a really
promising and we've seen it not just
here in hamilton jacobi equations but
people in computational fluid dynamics
and other kind of scientific areas where
they know the equation they want to
solve are using um now neural net
procedures to help them do this kind of
computation
okay so
in this you know scenario we define a
neural net where v theta so this is our
approximation of the value function here
x is the state space
and typically to find the parameters
like to train that neural net you'd be
you'd obtain those using supervised
learning where the value function is
known at some states over time but that
in itself is hard right because then you
have to actually compute the value
function at those states to be able to
use them to supervise the training of
that neural net
so
the key thing about this kind of
scientific uh
application of neural nets is that you
can use this the equation you know the
equation you want to solve
so you can use that as the source of
supervision and use self-supervised
learning so the pde itself is the source
of supervision and the loss that you use
in training is just the pd pde violation
error okay so if you're if that right
hand side of the loss function h is
non-zero it indicates that you're not
satisfying your pde and so you're trying
to you're training the system to try to
get your you know that function or the
magnitude of that function to zero and
it means you're solving your pde then
and the cool thing about that is you
know you don't have to sample the value
function and that's the key to scaling
so we um
we then just uh follow this loop we
randomly sample states and at
points in state and time we compute the
loss function we update the parameters
and repeat
okay so this is um we call this deep
reach so deep learning to compute
reachable sets um there's a lot of
details here that i don't really have
time to talk about but one of them is
the form of the neural net um and you
know this is all empirical right i mean
we can do these we can do these
computations and then we can compare
them to our grid based computations and
some functions that we know we can
compute analytically
but one of the keys to make this work
was to use something called a sinusoidal
representation network uh
siren which is a
a kind of
i guess in advance that came out of
stanford actually the computer vision
group here
and um the idea is that because we're
interested not only in you know the
value function itself but its derivative
over time and its gradient we wanted to
be able to have units in the neural net
which were differentiable and where
where you know the control input itself
is computed from the gradients so we use
um a sinus so we use sinusoidal uh um
activation functions for the neural net
and then we follow this training
procedure
and of course there's a lot you know the
size of the neural net the number of
neurons the learning procedure so we've
tried out a bunch of different things
and we've we've published this la this
uh this last year um but i think there's
still a lot to do here in this you know
in this but in this area in general
using neural nets to um aid you in
scientific computation
but the cool thing is that um so this
just shows you know the match for some
of these low dimensional problems where
we know the solution we've actually got
some sort of semi-analytic solutions to
these two aircraft collision avoidance
problems they're kind of our litmus test
um but that we can you know start to go
higher so this is a nine dimensional
three aircraft collision avoidance
problem so it's three aircraft uh it's
lateral so three xy and theta three
states each
you can't do relative anymore because
now it's three aircraft
and uh it was a um
this is a single pursuer two evader
problem
um so what we've shown here are the
projections of the reachable set
computed via deep reach which is the
pink set
for projected down onto the positions
coordinates x7 and x8 or the seventh and
eight state coordinate but they're the
position coordinates of the pursuing
aircraft and the evader aircraft or the
other two and if you do that thing that
we did earlier with the quadrotors where
you compute the the two the 3d reachable
set with the pursuer innovator one and
you compute the 3d reachable set with
the pursuer innovator 2 and you take the
union you get the blue set so here in
this example you can't do that nice
little decomposition trick we had before
in fact the actual reachable set is
closer we've we've gone back and we've
like numerically validated that the
actual reachable set is um
is
very you know closely represented by
this by this pink set that we compute
through deep reach and we did that by
like sampling points along the boundary
right just inside and just outside so
that's just shown stylistically here
that purple point we simulated that you
can see that you know that's a set which
is outside of the blue decomposed set
but inside the pink set
and so that's a point that actually
causes collision the pursuer is avail is
um is able to cause the loss of
separation indicated by this red line
here between the two agents you go below
that uh that mandated separation whereas
if you sample just outside the boundary
that's the gray dot you see that um
you see that the reachable set is
representative of a safe condition
okay so that's some that's some current
we're working on like reachability in
general is a challenging problem um it's
challenging numerically we need better
methods and this is you know one of them
that we've been working towards
we've got a um
like a
23-dimensional walking robot with kosher
srinath who's a professor at
berkeley in mechanical engineering which
we're computing domains of attraction
for for the different gates using deep
reach
okay so i'd like to now in the remaining
minutes of the talk talk about relaxing
some of these assumptions that we've
made for reachability
a computationally efficient method for
many agents and really looking at the
role of what is worst case best case how
do we use feedback and then we'll end by
talking about learning some of those
parameters that we'll introduce in this
in the second method
okay so i highlight the importance of
feedback here and and i'm going to
explain this method
through an example i think the idea of a
feedback nash equilibrium which is what
we're computed is best explained using
some visualizations through an example
and it's kind of actually when we were
developing this framework it's how we
started developing it and thinking about
what
how to incorporate
uh input constraints and state
constraints into a feedback game
okay so here the example will be this
highway driving scenario or just driving
scenario where there's kind of this idea
of merging the blue car is is merging
over and it's merging in front of this
yellow car so this uh polite maneuver on
the left is um is basically one that we
all strive to right the blue car which
is merging in front of the yellow it
speeds up so the yellow car doesn't have
to slow down so that's kind of the
desired polite maneuver
um but if you look at kind of the you
know state of the art in game theory
with state and input constraints that's
this open loop nash equilibrium and that
we've shown on the right basically the
car still merges but the blue doesn't
react so the yellow has to slow down and
that's because the
the open loop game doesn't capture this
key point that comes back comes through
feedback that what you assume the other
agent will do in reaction to what you're
doing that back and forth
okay so that's captured here and it's
what we do in real life in many
scenarios but it's not captured here the
yellow car like kind of the ego car here
we're thinking about has to slow down
this is um you know it's like that
hesitant behavior that you used to see
in autonomous vehicles when you know
there would be a car like stop it would
sort of stop even you know if a car was
slowing down in front of it so that that
you don't have a realistic assumption
about the interaction of the two
vehicles there's not that feedback
okay so
how did we start to think about this and
and getting towards like how you would
compute a feedback solution here so what
is uh is a little bit of an overview
here maybe captured stylistically so
let's suppose now okay so ego is the
blue vehicle and this red vehicle um it
may keep going straight or it may
change lanes so let's assume it's maybe
it's going to go straight with 80
percent prob or 0.8 probability and
change lanes with 0.2 probability so
what we do is um is we make two copies
of that vehicle one to represent one
hypothesis and one to represent the
other hypothesis so we kind of think
about this um
uh representation in terms of
multi like creating these kind of ghosts
vehicles that are going to represent
these different hypotheses we have about
the actions of the other agent so with
0.8 probability that car will go forward
and i've shaded the other one a little
lightly with 0.2 probability it'll
change lanes
okay so then maybe the ensuing
trajectory of the red vehicle might look
like that from the ego's point of view
and then the question is like what
should the ego vehicle do it has these
kind of two possibilities of what the
other vehicle could do
so we think about this whether we think
about this kind of closed loop or
feedback solution
in terms of ownership of constraints
um in a way we're kind of maintaining
multiple hypotheses about the intentions
of the other vehicles
so the
we define um a single variable here like
a a variable p which is the probability
of the red vehicle doing what it could
do a probability of a lane change so if
the probability of a lane change is
equal to one you know the um
the ego vehicle might follow a certain
action um and if the probability of the
lane change is zero it might find it it
might follow another action so that kind
of probability going between zero to one
it's like transferring the ownership of
those constraints from one vehicle to
another and then you could have
interpolating probabilities like this
sort of you know there's a maybe a 0.5
probability and then it does something
in between
so here the idea is that if p is equal
to one the ego vehicle is going to avoid
the hypothesized agent and if p is equal
to zero it's going to ignore the
hypothesized agent so in each case you
know the other agent or itself has that
ownership of constraints
and so we formulated that constraint
ownership problem
um basically you know it basically
becomes an optimization problem in terms
of this parameter of constraint
ownership and so for this interpolating
factor p whether it's between zero and
one we're going to get these varying
solutions whether you know which are
basically this kind of varying of
constraint ownership
this leads to what is a novel
optimization framework which is called a
generalized feedback nash equilibrium
um basically it's you know this
this constraint ownership instantiated
here as we generalize it we get to this
feedback nash equilibrium solution and
it's basically this framework where
which we kind of started with as our
desired polite maneuver like other
agents can be assumed to react to the
ego's intentions or its actions and so
the ego can follow you know its
basically follow its plan accordingly
um
okay so this is you know the play out of
that so you see that the feedback nash
equilibrium solution it's got that
feedback so you see the kind of desired
polite maneuver
um and then you can look at different
scenarios here so if you you can have
multiple hypotheses right so you could
have a single vehicle that has many
hypotheses or multiple vehicles each
with multiple hypotheses
so for example you know here this is the
intention of the red agent either it's
going to stay in lane or change lanes as
we saw we could for example have you
know the red agent is either going to
drive fast or drive at a normal speed
and then we could try to combine these
to you know um
stay in lane or change lanes so that
would be the assumption about the green
versus the assumption about the red and
we can you know play out these different
scenarios
so this is um this is a framework that
we've been exploring and computing
efficient solutions to we're actually uh
the code that we developed to compute
this is based on um a iterative linear
quadratic game formulation that we
developed with uh forest lane who's the
first author on this as well as david
fridovich kyle who are both former
students they just graduated
uh
david two years ago in forest last year
and david was here for a year as a
postdoc before starting his faculty
position at ut austin
so finally i think we're finishing up
pretty soon and i'd like to just end
with this last vignette which talks
about you know kind of going back to
that parameter p like how do you
how do you infer these parameters um
you know we're we're sort of talking
about a probability parameter or you
know a parameter that represents
something about
where we try to capture the behavior of
other agents in maybe a low dimensional
parameter set but then you know what do
you do with those parameters
and i think this has some nice tie-ins
to some of the work going on here so
inferring behavioral parameters
um to do this i'd also like to introduce
a third example which is um some work
that we did in conjunction with
oncodragon and
a number of students at berkeley some of
whom actually now all of whom who have
graduated
but the idea is to think about in this
work other agents and in particular
other agents as humans so as a as an
autonomous system how do we infer the
behavior of you know uh pedestrians
walking around or
are human-driven cars what are they
going to do so what are the actions of
those humans
and this is a model um that has been
used it has a long history um kind of
starting in cognitive psychology and
then moving in the past decades into
robotic path planning this is a
boltzmann model which indicates
a kind of probability of a human action
represented here by uh
as being
as being more probable the more
efficient it is towards certain goals
that you could encode and those goals
can be encoded through some value
function or q function which is a
function of the state and action of the
system
which may be parameterized by you know
certain things going on in the in the
system so in this scenario there's a
person walking along the robot's trying
to think about where that person might
be in the next few minutes or the next
few time steps you know knowing the
goals of that person allows a reasonable
representation of what that person might
do so basically value-driven people
and then the autonomous system using
this boltzmann type model to infer
what's the probability of the next few
actions so in in this case
if we encoded for example that door as
being one of the goals the regions of
high probability might be represented in
pink which would be like a straight line
towards that uh towards that door
that um
that model has been used and shown to be
quite effective in in
several different scenarios now for
robot path planning and something that
we looked at is this uh parameter beta
in the exponential there this is like
the inverse temperature parameter of the
boltzmann model and in this case it can
be used as kind of a model confidence
parameter or rationality parameter it's
sometimes called so if beta is
very low then that would indicate a
large spread of that probability
distribution and basically this
irrational behavior or like the human
choosing actions uniformly at random and
then as beta gets higher and higher you
get sort of a peakiness that you might
see here where the probability gets
higher and higher according to some
particular goals
so for example um you know if the person
sort of turned around and started doing
something that didn't seem like it was
efficient towards the goal then um one
might update beta and say okay well you
know we had kind of a high beta there
but we might have been wrong or this
person is acting irrationally so let's
uh let's lower beta and then that
probability distribution spreads out so
we did this this was work um a couple of
years ago uh so jaime fizzak andrea
baichi who is graduating this summer
sylvia herbert and david fritovich kyle
joined with them with
with me and anka
um and this is a it's a very simple i
mean i wouldn't even call it a learning
algorithm right it's just a bayesian
update on beta based on data that you're
capturing about what that person is
doing in real time and it's nice because
it's a single parameter like that what
was nice about what we did before you
had like a single probability which
everything rested on but it was it gives
you a fast or it gives you um guidance
towards some faster algorithms for
estimating you know what that person or
what that other vehicle is doing
uh i like showing oops i like showing
this so i will this is a just a
demonstration of that this is um jaime
and sylvia they're both crossing the lab
getting to their goals there's two quad
rotors and that quad those quadrotors
are also trying to cross the room
and you can see both of them moving
jaime's moving in a little erratic way a
little bit slower sylvia is crossing the
room
and the quadrotors are observing sylvia
and jaime here they're not really
observing them they're just observing
those um those fluorescent beads on
their caps through our our uh
our vicon system and um and then in real
time they're updating their beta
parameters so if you now look at that
bottom right hand corner of the screen
you'll see jaime and sylvia and they're
kind of next step probability
distributions
and it's interesting because you see
immediately jaime is kind of irrational
whereas sylvia she's moving a bit faster
towards the goal so she's kind of
perceived to be more rational so jaime's
beta coefficient we always joked with
him he had a low beta coefficient
um okay so let me just finalize the talk
now so we have you know that was just a
little vignette but we've talked about a
couple of different projects now where
um
we have tried to you know think about
inferring the behavior of other agents
um and that and then thinking about kind
of novel formulations that use that
inference and that was you know a single
probability parameter that was like an
interpolating probability or for example
a beta parameter and we've done a number
of these other projects
um but how do you infer those and so we
have you know different methods we've
been using to do that and i think that's
an interesting direction but andrea
baichie who is graduating this summer
asked um
like two years ago she started thinking
about well what if we actually didn't
need to infer that parameter what if we
asked if like often you don't often you
care about what you should do in
response to you know some other agent
where you have some model of their
behavior
and you kind of you know you could learn
um you know these parameters to indicate
you know to parameterize that model but
you might be interested in questions
like
how long is it going to take me to get a
high confidence in what that agent is
doing so that i can plan for myself
and she said aha that's a reachability
problem
why don't we define a reachability
problem over the learning algorithm
that's determining the parameter that's
helping us learn the parameter so the
dynamics are now the learning algorithm
itself
and the parameter becomes the state
and so it's kind of a novel use of
reachability to answer some important
questions about you know robotic in this
case robotic human interaction
so she um
so she you know in in this case we're
thinking about like for example uh you
know a bayesian update on the parameter
that we're interested in
um
but there's also information that we can
get about like watching what the person
or the other agent is doing and that
becomes an input to that dynamic system
that we're using for learning right i
mean that's what the learning algorithm
is it's it's looking at what the person
is doing and it's using that as
real-time control on its on that
learning algorithm dynamics
so why not do reachability on that um so
you can ask questions like and answer
questions like what is the best case
time to learn or worst case time to
learn
you know how should we initialize the
robot to be able to get the most
information out of that scenario
okay so uh andrea's actually worked on a
number of different problems um in in
kind of this format
and um the one i'll just end the talk
with is this uh driving scenario which
is this um you know car asking is it
gonna go straight or is it going to turn
left because i would like to turn left
and so that
that car we can kind of put a learning
algorithm on a parameter in this case we
use a like a beta parameter indicating
you know what is its goal is its goal
towards to turn left or is its goal to
go forward
and the dynamic system is not just the
learning algorithm it's kind of the
joint dynamics the original state of the
system
augmented with the parameter that we're
trying to learn so that's the new state
and so the dynamics are the dynamics of
the original system the physical
dynamics augmented with the learning
algorithm so it's like learning in
again higher dimensions so again the
it's critical to be able to have
reachable set computations that work in
high dimensions but it's interesting
what we can do with those once we have
those algorithms
okay this just describes these different
examples but let's just step through
finally so um we as the robot are trying
to figure out whether or not we can turn
left how we should do that
and um and these are the two
hypotheses we have about the red car so
if the human driven red car goes forward
or goes left these are the possible
trajectories and so this is um this is
that bayesian update right that's the
learning algorithm that we're trying to
uh figure out you know can we by looking
at the actions of that vehicle figure
out what it's going to do it's kind of
like mimicking what we do as drivers
when we're trying to figure out if we
can actually solve this problem
so so we turn this into a like a
contingency plan what should i do now
knowing that i may have to branch to
either kind of you know make make sure i
stop so i don't go into the path of that
vehicle if it is going straight but so i
can eventually turn left
and so the we can use reachability to
compute this time to learn the worst
case time to learn how long will i have
to observe that other vehicle and what
it does so that i can gain high enough
confidence in what it does so that i can
um plan a safe path and that
intermediate time to learn we just need
a contingency plan
and that is you know this white
trajectory here so after those few steps
the reachability computes that it will
have enough confidence in that bayesian
update so it can determine whether or
not that vehicle is going straight or
turning left so so we can take our
appropriate action which is either to
kind of stall or just make the left turn
okay so this is just the play out of
that
there's the branching point
and the ensuing trajectory
so the idea here is really to try to use
these safety based calculations not just
in traditional ways for multi uh for you
know vehicle systems but use them as
kind of a an inference develop
an understanding not just of how to
learn parameters of an inference model
but can we analyze the learning of the
parameters of that inference model so we
can use that for our own planning
okay let me summarize
we talked about kind of three research
projects we talked about the background
of reachability in some examples and
some computational things we're doing
recently with that um we talked about
the
uh the importance of feedback and what
it means in terms of an example and that
led us to a formulation which was a
generalized feedback nash equilibrium
and that led us to think about you know
parameters so low dimensional parameter
representations of other agents
and then we started thinking about
learning those parameters so whether
it's learning the rationality parameters
of other agents or learning this
probability that's that's something that
we're working on
and reachability is one of the methods
we're using for that
so we've been doing a number of other
related projects i mean we continue a
lot of work in reachability and safety
and one of the projects that we've been
doing involves
really integrating perception into
control loops so this is another set of
projects that i didn't talk about today
but we we've been interested in how you
know using kind of state-of-the-art
perception combined with
planning and control model-based
planning and control we might use
reachability as a way of verifying
safety of that joint perception planning
um and control problem and so we've been
working on
some uh kind of social navigation
problems where you know we incorporate
safety functions first of all with some
known obstacles um and so some of these
are basically just sort of mapping out
known obstacles and using safety
functions so errors in the perception
module are not affecting the safety of
the overall vehicle but then also
incorporating
learned methods for social navigation so
for robots navigating around people
moving in spaces um and you know kind of
learning about uh the the best way to
maneuver around people and this is work
that sarah poland who's a fairly new
student in the lab has been working on
with that i'd like to conclude and i'd
like to thank a number of students and
former students the students in bold are
still here at berkeley are still up
there at berkeley working with me
actually
andrea and dungan are graduating this
summer
but a lot of this work is work of
students who've
just graduated recently or graduated in
the past in particular i'd like to thank
for the generalized feedback nash
equilibrium forest lane who's now on the
faculty at vanderbilt university and
david fridovich kyle who's on the
faculty at ut austin
um and uh the work um in um
in inferring beta was done by a number
of students who've also graduated as i
said jaime and sylvia and david and
andrea and then sawmill did the deep
reach work and a number of former
students just worked on problems in um
you know reachability but also safe
learning how we learn parameters of
reachability and still make guarantees
about it so and i'd like to thank some
of our
projects including this wonderful nasa
university leadership initiative project
which is run through stanford marco
pavone runs that project so it's a great
collaboration and thank you for
attending and being such a great
audience
you